hello everyone it's future alana uh
before we get into this episode there
are a couple of things i wanted to say
the first
is we talk about doing the live
version of episode 71 next week
uh we are not going to be able to do
that i just have a bunch of travel plans
that are kind of up in the air and the
dates could change so we're probably
going to delay doing
a live episode to celebrate 70 episodes
of play watch listen until
i am actually solidly back in
uh la i'm not sure when that'll be yet
we'll keep you all updated
number two there was an issue with
episode 69 publishing on certain
platforms um i'm not actually sure why
it's still stuck
i have reached out to the platforms for
help
um hopefully they can get back to me at
some point about it
but um yeah it is an issue that i'm
aware of it just is stuck on
pending on the hosting platform that i
use only on two platforms and i'm not
sure why so sorry about that
number three is this episode we talk a
lot about
um the games industry and loving working
in the games industry so i just wanted
to provide
the context that this was all recorded
prior to the activision blizzard
lawsuit um and all of the news
surrounding that i just wanted to be
clear that we are not referencing the
kind of behavior that
exists in that lawsuit obviously and to
say that i really do love the games
industry despite being aware of some
very glaring and unfortunately
consistent in my opinion um
workplace culture problems it is
a real problem with that said here is
episode
70. by the way i probably had sex the
latest of of all of everybody here
weeks ago well fingers crossed it was
traveler and that's it um
yeah and that was a and even then you
think a syringe a bottle of wine and a
big talk
um so so romantic
i just if if you
for for anybody especially a guy though
just
genetically biologically speaking
we're just grunts heavy forehead knuckle
walkers i feel like
if if you just could could
communicate if i could just communicate
to my younger self like dude
if you expect to receive you better be
willing to give
and even better give
first and your chances of receiving are
higher
is that a safe probably true also don't
be dj khaled that's all i'm saying
who oh the guy with the big champagne
bottle and the
what well that's drake yeah no either
works you should be neither of those
people i don't understand why oh he's
the guy that says i never will
yes because he's the king i miss this
what no he's not
he's he's he's all he's not in the same
way that henry v was
he he refuses to uh perform
cuddlingis because he's the king i don't
do that is what he said um and he's like
no i buy her [ __ ]
i'm the king um so his logic is that
kings can't do that quite public cell
phone there really that's what i'm
thinking you just probably admitted that
you've never given a woman an orgasm and
that's okay
well what's so funny to me about that is
everyone is entitled to their
preferences he's not obligated to like
it but i love that the obl but the
justification is not i don't like it
it's because i'm the king yeah it's hard
that's below me that's the issue i can't
because patriarchy right yeah that's
what means literally
he thinks it's below him
thank you buddy i love that we're
continuing it's episode
70 and none of us even yeah this is the
most episode 69 so far
this should be 69. this there should be
a fan order of the episodes we need to
make sure that we don't canonically
break anything that's revealed we need
to swap these episodes yeah
i could because this is very much a
tokyo drift situation we need to like
move the title
around yeah email spotify hey spotify
won't publish episode 69
and i don't know why it's just been
stuck on pending how unrealistic
i saw people saying that on twitter yeah
i don't know what to do about it
yeah i probably need to email them and
be like is this because i originally had
quotes in
the title but i changed that and it
still went published so i don't know
in any case should we do
12 30 next week for the live for episode
71
let me check my calendar this is an
insight behind them so otherwise we can
figure that out
at some point during the process and i
will edit it in to
the podcast i'm available
i'm available scheduling are you
available
i mean i think it's you know it's
beneath me i'm the king
it's below you certainly think i should
blow me that's follow me
oh there it is all right well i'll
confirm that via audio edit
in the future but that's what we will
aim for is the 27th at 12 30 p.m pacific
time
sounds good to me um but this is episode
70.
i'm going to enter this show they've
been recording
oh my god who are we we're falling apart
we did last time
it wasn't in three minutes hello
everyone
welcome to play watch listen i'm alana
pierce i'm a video game writer that's
troy baker he's a video game actor
that's mike pithel he's a video game
director and that's austin winter he's a
video game composer
we mostly talk about video games what
austin's gonna possibly
say something i love inhale
your face is very what
no no i mean as always i have a million
uh
uh thoughts uh in my head but i wasn't
about to interject with something ultra
pressing that needed to be addressed you
know by the council
immediately i was going to ask
if how everybody feels about these
recent kotaku headlines
i don't i don't wanna
your answer is i don't wanna that's
that's
let's just let the camera linger on troy
for a moment
that's uh david attenborough in the raid
it's troy it's rubbing his face
i don't i don't want to have as strong
like this this is this is a borderline
sin issue with me i don't want to have a
strong of opinion as i have on this
it's like it bothers me i don't life
would be better if you didn't care in
other words yeah i want to be i want to
be more unaffected i want to feel like
that's flappable about it and just not
care but i just i
man it really i and i don't know what
well i do know why i
like i can i can articulate why it
bothers me so much but i wish that it
didn't
and it points out the fact that i still
have work that i need to do on myself
because
it just this righteous indication built
up within me and i i just
i it's not good it's not healthy very
much of you troy look at you
being what 30 32 next year that's pretty
great actually oh happy birthday we're
seeing some groceries um
so for anyone who's missed what's
happening 32
next year oh happy birthday that's a
good little one-two punch if someone
tells you that there's something soon
even if it's in five years you say oh
happy birthday
uh for anyone who's missed any of this
basically there was the most recent uh
kotaku
headline slash tweet that went out uh
that called an x-com mobile port
[ __ ] um in the tweet that was their
actual
headline and then the previous one i
could probably find it
quite easily was referring to
basically making fun of a call of duty
producer
i hope i'm saying that oh yes crazy
studio yeah
the studio i was ahead of you directed
it
visiting europe shooting old guns was
very hard work and these
are obviously both pretty scathing
uh headlines come from kotaku yeah i had
the article about
uh glenn showfield still open because i
had read half of it and i wanted to
finish reading because i was curious if
there was any redeeming quality and they
they blatantly say
you know uh traveling and doing research
and
you know watching videos on youtube
sounds like a vacation you know unlike
the people finding bugs for 12 hours a
day
and it's like i just thought man what an
axe to grind like
this this this uh is a
but it's what about ism you know what i
mean it's it's it's
it's systemic it's a systemic issue that
someone is conveniently uh
you know employing and into their quote
writing
for for the purposes of clicks i'm
watching that growth just recede back
you know in the
marriott super mario brothers where they
have the devolution gun this is
happening to you in real time
yeah dude it's like those layers and i
don't necessarily think it's for clicks
i don't actually generally believe that
i know that
a lot of people tend to think like any
headline or any article they wrote this
for clicks
the reality of that in my experience
being a journalist for nine years
not once did i ever even one time think
about clicks
never i
feel like that applies to and i've also
written kotaku right so sure
some of the stuff that i pitched to
kotaku was turned down because they were
like nobody cares about
concrete genie they're not clicking on
that but that's a subject not a topic
um
that you wouldn't write about a game
that nobody is talking about
right now but i could still write
whatever i wanted about that game and
would not be like you have to get this
amount of clicks
it's make sure it's at least relevant so
it's worth out time
i'm not saying there's a quota but i am
definitely saying i think they're
thinking about that when they wrote this
they have to be inherently journalism
from the very beginning
of the printing press people are doing
this like what will people want to read
what will people what will drive
subscriptions what will
get people to buy this so that is that
is and nowadays we'll start a
conversation right
yes should i be part of the zeitgeist
how can i get retweets it's the same
thing
just saying that i don't think the whole
thing is centered around that i think
this is just
genuinely somebody's snarky opinion
i don't think it's just that's not the
problem it's not someone having someone
have a snarky opinion
now it got published
have your opinion go to your own twitter
do whatever you want to do that's fine
but somebody in an authoritative
position
in a managerial supervisory position
said
this and layout no longer applies
i mean i was in journalism you know when
there were
hey this is we're going by column inch
and that no longer applies anymore it's
if anything it's now
how many things can we get out of the
day can we be on
every thumb scroll somehow
a part of that conversation but
the indictment of someone's character
and by and large just poking at
at an industry and and the practices of
it is so
[ __ ] old hat and it's i agree
completely
so that that but that it is based upon
the fact that
they know it'll happen they'll get it
clicks they know someone's going to stop
i did sure but i think that they also
just believe what they wrote that's all
i'm saying
i don't think it's entirely fabricated i
think there's an intent there to
make the statement that they make about
the qa stuff i think
it's kind of buried in the article like
it's something you actually have to kind
of get through quite a few paragraphs to
get to but i
i feel like that was the main reason for
the piece was not actually necessarily
to kind of
i mean obviously the headline does what
the headline does but like it feels like
that was the intention the intention was
to make a point about the difference in
those two roles right i feel like they
may have written this
thinking that people would love it
because it's very easy to be
anti-activision director
call of duty yeah he's and director very
easy
for for what it's worth i mean and
here's here's what he wrote he was
sledgehammer
he was sledgehammer and here's the
reason why he kind of hits home with me
i worked for that man and i saw his work
ethic
that guy is incredibly principled
the level of authenticity and first of
all how about this
you launch a call of duty title that and
you you give
years over to your life to to dedicate
to make sure that
it's an authentic experience it's a
groundbreaking experience for a a
you know a marquee title that people are
like what are you gonna do for me this
time and you're like we're gonna really
break ground and we're going to take it
out
out of you know the the past where it's
been and
we're actually launched in the future
we're going to put jump jets on your
suit all that kind of [ __ ]
we're going to do something no one has
ever done before and we're going to cast
the actor of the time and we're going to
shoot with him troy they got me dude
they've done it and they but it's the
same every year though so
and then you can't even talk about it
anymore because it instantly gets cursed
by proxy because
the guy that they got in there wanted to
diddle anyway
i have a tremendous amount of spa and
then you go you know what we're going to
go off and we're going to venture and
start our own thing i have a tremendous
amount of respect
for glenn and so anybody that wants to
to malign his character
i also think that there's a vast
unappreciated like
like failure of appreciation for
the burden that is shouldered by someone
in a leadership position
with hundreds of jobs at their like
especially on a
project of that scale where literally
hundreds of people's livelihoods
millions of dollars worth of payroll is
basically contingent on the success of
upholding that and
the process of whatever that process is
you know which entails travel and
research and doing all the idea of
oh well i'm basically just vacationing
in europe it's like
if that were true it would [ __ ] the
company it would it would you know like
and people and anytime people do you
know
claim to be working and they're
basically just just doing dick all
they get they get [ __ ] let go because
they can't
yield results for what they're doing i i
don't i don't understand
i think that's why it has bothered so
many people so much is that you expect
kotaku which you know unlike the youtube
channels who've been making
[ __ ] call of duty [ __ ] activision as a
publisher
for videos for years where they say that
they're lazy devs they don't change
anything
you don't expect that to come from a
website that is
further into the industry that's what it
is it's like you just expect them to
know
better than that that that stuff is
really hard and that sure qa is a really
tough job but so are a lot of the other
jobs none of
none of it's easy and i think that's why
it hurts so many people so much
it's just the utter dismissal of a
director's
role i think as well the thing that's
like potentially worrying to other kind
of creatives in the industry
is that you know that was an interview
it's like it was an edge thing right it
wasn't
an interview for edge or something yeah
it wasn't even their article
like you when you're doing press you're
you know journalists come to you
usually kind of very positive right
press
they're excited by games they're either
a fan of you or a fan of games as a
medium
and you do get asked a lot of questions
about like how come you're so awesome
um and it's your job in that situation
to kind of like respond to that with
humility and kind of
well that's a really interesting
question obviously you know blah blah
blah
but it's it there is kind of uh that is
an
interesting question i literally happen
to someone who works for me uh today
with an interview he was doing where one
of the questions you got was literally
how come you guys just make such great
games it's like how do you navigate that
as a question like
how do you present how do you respond to
that in a way that doesn't make you
sound like a dick when you're then
quoted you know
in something else so yeah it's it's kind
of the guy was the guy didn't run into a
into a press outlet and yell about how
brilliant he was he was asked questions
he tried to answer them honestly about
what yeah right it wasn't his twitter
feed where he was like look how hard
this is
exactly like he wasn't him saying
trailers yeah
i'm sitting on a beach kicking back
going research
blessed you know whatever the [ __ ] it's
it's a weird one because i because i
do i do think there's a i think there's
a good article to be written
on the subject of like you know how does
the industry treat qa we all know that
qa get a really bad
kind of treatment in the industry i
think it's a totally valid thing to be
writing about and being a bit snarky
about and kind of taking the big
play studios to task on because those
those staff are treated badly and
they're fired quickly
i thought this article was going to do
well i thought i think i don't know
yeah everyone's going to be like i think
this guy i think there's content there
that
can maybe be presented in a better way
but like it's it's
i think it's valid to criticize that
stuff it's where it gets where
why why riled so many people up was the
personal aspect of it and the
aspect of that how picking on a dude for
how about
his job critique but not criticize you
know what i mean like you can
criticize criticize like criticize the
no no no not this process i'm talking
about criticizing the the practices of
um companies i'm talking that like you
know
austin mentioned you know hundreds of
people on payroll
that's true but triple a regularly fires
50 100 people in one fell swoop because
they want to make the books balance a
little bit more before the stock
market notices
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
bad practices you can
kind of criticize and for better or
worse this article got us all to talk
about it for a week so
it's true it did its job yeah man but
that's like so
sucks don't get me wrong like that guy
didn't deserve to be the center of the
fire and i completely agree with you on
that training but it's also pt barnum
you know what i mean
like we'll we'll get on the 101
and there could be a tire in the road
and it literally will
will shut down an entire freeway so the
the fact that people notice something or
talk about something does not
necessarily speak
to the caliber of whatever you know
we're we're idiots we'll we'll look at
anything but i
just
yeah i think the idea of that that
article
anyone who would be naive enough to
think that framing an article like that
would be
somehow a way to crack open a discussion
about qa practices i mean that would be
absurd but i also don't think that
that's the
motivation if it if it at all if it's at
all consistent with the x-com one which
just seemed like it was just randomly
taking a pot shot
it's at a at a game like it
in it's funny because what something
this is all like
kind of perfectly adjacent to a thing
that i've been
um thinking about and i keep meaning to
john williams to
keep meaning to bring up here um harry
gerksen williams
wow once wrote an article about uh how
much he hated
john williams's work yeah i thought star
wars music was john williams was lazy
yeah he was like star wars music is [ __ ]
and it turns out he was just listening
to like john williams first draft of the
star wars soundtrack
because williams of all of all composers
an interesting pull there
the um uh he didn't write that
um he didn't did he
five years ago you're right he adapted
it that was written for
it was a japanese japanese name
although where did that japanese
composer arguably get certain
inspiration for that well he from
trans yeah it's transparently to me that
it sounds blatantly like it's from speed
but that's mark martina not harry
gregson is that not clever
that's harry gregson moves i thought i
was gonna win and you bested me again
i i saw i saw you coming there's no
there's no there's no question
that i came for the king and i missed
[Laughter]
the king about elections below me
i was trying to think of what to make of
it it came for the king and then there's
like there's another joke to be made
we should have milked this for a lot
longer the king did come but
came before the king didn't come well
mel brooks a la
history of the world is just sitting
here saying all of this right now
yep um but
yeah equally important as the
inspirations
of metal gear solid um the
the this there i've i've a friend of
mine tweeted the other day
about um there's like this
trend that he's been observing
that i see it you'd see it in the sort
of media or the intelligentsia
types the commentary types of a
of a what the coffee people yes
um of this kind of
like weird i hate the thing that i love
trend and this kotaku article feels like
a perfect demonstration of that like
theoretically a gaming site
that seems like it's got an axe to grind
about gaming and i said and i remember
responding to him saying
you know i feel like i see that a lot
even among the development
community i see it's like every time
i see bad news i see a lot of folks
sharing on twitter
things along the lines of like ah this
[ __ ] industry you know
like [ __ ] and i'm like get out
is it yeah i said is it is it that is it
lots of people have valid reasons to not
think
i'm not saying be a shameless
sycophantic apologist that thinks
everything is perfect and anyone that
dares alter the status quo one iota is a
heretic
not even close to that like we can all
be improving what we do all the time
but the idea that anything short of
utopian
impossible perfection is like [ __ ] this
thing man because
the other place that i see it is i see
people who hate gamers
uh they make games for people they
despise
and i think what are you doing with your
life
yeah you know like i i see i i see this
amongst all cr it's not this is not just
developers you know like i'm not i'm not
uh
rounding them up because i'll see it
amongst composers you know like oh my
god
as well i can't write the kind of music
i want to write because you know
i got to dumb it down it's too you know
the uh
mute people can't stop right understand
austin i don't like it stop
messaging me at 3am i genuinely would if
i thought
the listeners are a bunch of shitbags
who are not worth my time and
like what to whom am i writing or for
whom if not them
ultimately even even in a collaboration
where i'm working with a game developer
we're ultimately both aimed at the gamer
in the end i'm not
writing for my boss as much as i'm
writing for
the game which is aimed at the community
and i just don't understand it really am
i
am i being overly sensitive or is there
this seemingly this trend where it's
kind of cool to [ __ ] on
players and it's cool to [ __ ] on the
industry no
there is um and i think that that
powerful statement there a lot of that
comes that's not a coffee mug by next
week by the way
oh wow that's good i'm mike bethel
you might know me from some games gold
dummies was alone
that's like mike's mike's read for a
very good
better better call your freeze frame was
just so beautiful
my name is
[Music]
no i do think that there is you know a
[ __ ] gamers
thing but i think that it also
comes from gamers saying [ __ ] devs so i
feel like it you know it's sort of this
ongoing product within itself where all
parties do it
to one another uh and thus yes the
extremities exist and i also don't think
that it's healthy i mean i've i've
always said
see so many journalists complain about
e3 and my thought was always the minute
that i'm not excited about e3 every year
or even press conferences in general i
shouldn't be in the industry but i still
get so
[ __ ] stoked about all of this stuff
even if it's you know
fancy flashy marketing i'll cry
sometimes because i just love video
games i've always been like the minute
that i stopped being cynical
i should get out make room for someone
else i think that everybody
regardless there's there's some kind of
button and i don't know what it is
inside of who we are as people
that we have a proclivity towards
criticism
and there's there's some kind of haptic
feedback
that we get of control maybe to where
it's like i feel better if i
wh because we did the same thing with
sports well you know they didn't play
like they should have and what i would
have done in that fourth
set down of the body
quarterback yeah it's like there's
there's this feeling of like
i have agency in something you know and
i think the same thing happens in
journalism to where people come
forward and they go i'm gonna write an
article about
my thoughts on this particular thing and
if i
am somehow being
i'm not being disparaging i'm being
critical
and if i'm being critical then that
elevates my opinion above the thing in
order for me to
look down and have an opinion of how
they should better
do it it's like get [ __ ] ring dude
you try it it's hard it's hard making a
game
like you were talking about last week
where you said if you whatever you think
your length of the game is going to be
it's going to be longer
because it just takes more than when you
thought it would
but i don't think things being hard
means that they
don't deserve any criticism i'm not
saying they don't deserve criticism i
think that the intent
behind most people for doing it is not
to go
hey guys i want to see if i can't help
the industry be better it is
look at the shitty thing that they're
doing i think the majority of people are
saying because they want things to be
better i think so too
they you might disagree with them in
terms of what shape you think they
what shape they want it to be better
what is it
what is its efficacy i would look at
that do you think that
that most of the time an article that is
written from a crit like
the perfect example is this kotaku
article do you feel that that in
any way move the needle do you think
that anybody at sledgehammer activision
or other studios industry why i went hey
guys
are we really we should look at our
practices do you think that happened at
all do you think there was
any positive change i think a lot of gay
i think a lot of game developers who
regularly give interviews saw that
article
and thought i'll never talk to kotaku
again
no i think for in my case i can't speak
for myself
i thought i've probably said some cringy
stuff in the past that taken out of
context would look make me look like a
prat probably a lot of it in context
maybe you know how easy
every single sentence ever could be
taken out of context and made to look
right but i
i i think i think individuals and
industries and companies benefit
from introspection and criticism but was
that
the article but i think the intent of
the article was hey make sure you watch
your words because we'll
[ __ ] with you it was look at the
business practices and and
you going on a vacation and you sitting
and watching videos is how you consider
research
that a a a
haphazard by-product that someone goes
i'm going to watch what i say it cannot
be attributed to the person writing the
article
i think the right person in the article
i'm not arguing that it was
brilliantly written but i think the
intention i think the intention of the
article was
uh was you know to to to to point out
the qa thing i mean that was ultimately
the
i agree with that this the the better it
was whether they were successful or not
at
it it's it's five percent of the total
article though i mean
it's not oh and by the way people people
can be unsuccessfully intentioned
like you can fail at achieving something
that you set out to achieve i'm
answering the question of what were they
trying for
i think they were trying for that and i
i respectfully disagree i think you
i think it's because that's the part of
the article
that you feel that way mike because
that's the one highlight of the article
that spoke most to you
because it's a subject on which you have
a lot of common ground but it was
okay it was a passing mention in the
article and it was the only thing close
to substance of like
a a criticism of practices i mean i
i see your point i'm locked into my own
subjective perspective so i would
absolutely concede that that that could
be an explanation for
what's what i'm i'm and it's not like
and obviously you you you have kind of a
you know that's like a cause you care
about and it's a thing you care about in
terms of how you lead your company so
it's going to speak if
if the one if the one mention that they
hit like like
i remember once going to uh to uh
a talk of um um everyone's favorite
uh gearbox randy uh and um
he made a comment about uh gearbox has
by far the most progressive
sharing this was at pax dev uh probably
10 years ago and he said
um gearbox has by far the most
aggressive
and progressive profit sharing amongst
its employees
and like when our games do well every
person in the company does really well
like
we are the most you know ahead of the
curve they made these very big
statements i caught them in the hallway
and i said i'm curious if your composers
are a part of that
uh and it was like oh i got a lunch
gotta go uh
and uh and you know in in fairness there
are independent contractors who are not
employees of the companies and i get
that that's
but he may talk to a big game about like
and you know
and i thought yes you know i don't think
the composer you know
uh alana's favorite uh danish composer
uh contributing to borderlands like i
don't think that that's a substantially
lesser contribution
definitely not i do have a friend who's
still getting fat royalties from gearbox
though
still yeah again all
i'm not making a value judgment i just
remember saying you know
there's some pretty crucial roles that i
suspect are not being included in this
statement about how benevolently amazing
you
are and i guess you know this is the one
only time i've ever interacted with him
no
you know whatever i don't i don't i
don't i i don't have an agenda here i
just remember saying you know this is
probably not as
fully as angelic of a scene as you were
portraying it to be considering the
massive contribution music has and again
you applied some criticism
my point being my point being that like
he did what he said
no no there was absolutely an
implication in a subtext to my question
that was intended but
that that i i i'm simply saying it's my
version of this same phenomenon where
you know it may well be that a thousand
employees made out like bandits because
of profit
profit sharing and three composers who
were independent contractors didn't but
that's of course because of my bias
that's the one thing i'm going to notice
i'm using it as a corollary to the
article and by the way
if i can say this i am whenever i do
anything like if if if there's a
performance or whatever if i put it out
into the world
there is an unspoken understanding that
i have
that is going to get criticized and i am
i i welcome it
and i even look to look what did i
change my name to
this whoever said this
to me it just made me laugh it made me
what was that about
that and you know what but i didn't get
it i didn't know
listen troy's name on zoom right now is
falling apart between
gigs because somebody wrote that in the
comments last week
on youtube last week and i want that
you've fallen apart between
you do you ever are you ever truly
between gigs it seems like you're always
doing something directly
i i think are you recording a voiceover
right now is
constitutes between gigs because he he
came out of the booth and he's heading
straight back he's one of them
on a friday it it it has stayed with me
i want you to know that you are seen and
you were heard whoever you are
because it's such it's such a wonderful
thing i was like
look i i took the opportunities like am
i falling apart between gigs
and then and then it was like that
moment in liar liar where you know jim
carrey
you know wakes up and he's just like
i've had better
it's like where you go from how can i
say such a horrible thing to actually
bringing me joy
and i was like i i at first same thing
as i said in the very beginning i was
like man i need to get a hold of myself
because i am just as subject to anybody
else for for something impacting me in a
way that that
uh that brings about a negative a
response and it was like
at first i was like who do you think you
were like well hold on a second am i
falling apart between gigs like wait a
minute am i between gigs
well actually no right now i'm not i was
like you think i stopped working
but all of this and then you have to
think about if you stopped working
this this this nice don't shouldn't take
this much
like don't worry about it i'm with you
on this i get it but the thing is is
like
to speak to intent just like the writer
of this kotaku article
this person could be like man was
falling apart between gigs
that could have been light-hearted and
wonderful and just because they didn't
attach some
whatever new lexicon we've had in the
last five years of an emoji
to contextualize something they could
have generally thought it was funny i
was like you know what
i can just as easily choose to take this
as a wink wink hey we're friends we're
buddies as much as i can be a j
a jab so i when something is not
willfully intentionally harmful
it's just as likely that it is willfully
intentional that at least the intent
behind it
was to make somebody smile so i'm
choosing to have this make me smile
am i bearded that's very cool if your
intent was to make a smile or if you
actually uh feel bad for troy i don't
know
i'd say i'm falling apart it's a heat
wave in the uk i'm a sweater
okay calm down first of all i've been
there
i went running in london on the hottest
day
recorded it was like 41 degrees
okay in london i was like man it's hot
for london like a record high today in
the uk
uh i was like australian yeah
well i came from australia but i'm stuck
here because they don't let me back
and i'm used to the hot weather it's
just their months are flipping it's a
different heat though that's the thing
we also don't have air con like i i'm
finding in california it's lovely i
don't mind a hot day in california but
yeah because we are like turn the
[ __ ] ac down in san francisco
sometimes labor day weekend that first
weekend in september it gets to 41.42
it's happened a couple of times
nobody has [ __ ] air conditioning
people are bringing
fans into their rooms and buying out all
these hot air around
yeah it's great get the fix where they
can it's terrible
how did we get to this i don't know oh
mike said he's falling apart
i'm falling apart maybe that maybe the
commenter means
i'm very hot maybe the comments are
meant me maybe that's what it was no
i'm sure they know who we are i've seen
them i've seen people in the i've seen
people in the youtube comments like
refer to people who aren't on the show
like steve's really made some good
points in this episode it's like there's
no one that's clearly
that's he's established law mike that's
clearly he's not the guy
yeah he's steve steven steve is kind of
more a part of this than we are
didn't i make it didn't i put it in the
twitter there i finally yes
i've missed it yeah you did it it was
like steve forever or something
maybe this is where i wasn't on if there
was ever a problem blame steve
we haven't we have an imaginary
episodes that we can forget our own
[ __ ] i don't know the law
i don't know the law i'm not really and
yet
like people criticizing like star trek
for example for not being real star trek
because
you know this thing contradicts the lore
from this episode 38 years ago
look at us 70 episodes of us just
bullshitting and we contradict ourselves
and
and we don't have to keep track of 500
episodes of television ea would make a
mass effect tree master
did you know that i didn't say that oh i
was the one saying they were
you said that if they did it would
indicate there was more mass effect
coming
which i still think you're probably
right about we just don't know about you
yeah yeah but no of course we do they
showed an announcement trailer for a new
mass effect did they
yes absolutely missed that well like an
e3 no i think you're just forgetting
because it was like
lobbed in with the legendary uh stuff i
think last year's
n7 day but it was it was it's just a
teaser it was just a teaser
you i think you're just forgetting that
you know this because it it it
it uh probably spoke about it on an
application i was like
it was like a there was a teaser very
short teaser that said absolutely
nothing
about what the game is it just was like
a liara esque
looking character finding like an n7
helmet
uh in the snow or something and it was a
very brief little teaser of like oh
i'm trying to have this right yeah but
back to
um much earlier like falling apart
troy made a comment
regarding articles uh potentially being
for the betterment
of the games industry and that was a
wonderful comment yes let's talk about
we've had this conversation before
but journalists aren't writing articles
for
game developers they are writing
articles for
the audience and the truth what if the
audience is game developers though but
in some cases
but that's got to be a pretty small
amount one percent
is it overwhelmingly players then or at
least
players overwhelmingly players yes and
the the thing the one thing that annoys
me about this i i
dislike this article i don't agree with
it i'm like i'm not a fan of it
uh i would never have written something
like that and if someone on my team had
written something like that it'd be like
this is
probably coming from an uninformed place
did you consider reaching out to anyone
for comment about research that goes
into games and see how hard that is have
we interviewed anyone on the topic have
we
spoken to qa about how they feel about
the opportunities other schedules like
do some research
how many books you have to own as a
director just looking forward to
required it's a lot
it's tough clearly it's not all on
youtube you go on youtube and then you
realize oh actually to read a book
related that's the one thing that gets
me about it is that
youtubers do this [ __ ] all the time and
they get to make way more money for
themselves individually and nobody says
a [ __ ] word
we have these standards for press when
they do the exact same thing
and there are a million more youtube
videos that are along the lines of [ __ ]
all call of duty executives for things
that aren't even true
and they're just allowed to make money
but the journalist is scrutinized so
heavily the same thing i think applies
to the
uh xcom thing where they called the game
[ __ ] um from
everything i can see from that game in
my opinion it does look very bad
but i would never call it [ __ ] i don't
generally speak about games that way but
i'm also not gonna be shy if i think
they look bad and i do think it looks
really bad
um it looks like it doesn't have a lot
of x-com going on it's very
odd to call it [ __ ] and to have that
come from an outlet like kotaku is very
strange
because i think that's we see them as
internal but youtubers do it all the
[ __ ] time why does nobody care
they have bigger audiences sometimes and
we're just like
but isn't that there isn't isn't the
question isn't the answer baked in the
question because a youtuber is
the branding from the beginning is here
is me
in my box representing me kotaku
and polygon and ign and everywhere else
is purporting to come from the same
philosophical headspace as the new york
l.a times the new york times
like they may they may they they so
there is a
certain integrity that is
presumed whether they whether they have
it or not just by virtue of like being a
site that aggregates these things
yeah you know they like it wasn't it
wasn't the the the article was
was written by ian walker who i don't
know who that is
oh well obviously not yeah like but but
the point is it's not ianwalker.com
no you're right it's ian walker you know
on behalf of
in a way kotaku paid for by the way it's
a kotaku article
it was a this this was paid for that's
that's the thing that also makes a
little bit of a difference every opinion
you read on the internet is paid for
nothing right but that's why that's why
i that's why i
that's why that's the only reason why i
would never say that this person should
not be allowed to have this opinion
um and i don't feel like it's not if
kotaku wants to say that they
are a an aggregator of people's snarky
opinions and that's the branding like
you know like uh like the onion or
something like f who cares i
that i don't i'm not here to police
thought or writing or i don't give a
[ __ ]
but i do think that that when you're
when this is just
answering your question why don't we
give a [ __ ] when
youtubers randomly rail and it's like
because they're doing they're fulfilling
their one
promise yeah sometimes
all right i just tweeted
troy we told you don't you told you troy
oh boy i just tweeted to prove your
point is like
everything is paid for in some way or
another
there's an opinion that i can put out i
had nothing to do with mike
there's an opinion that i could put i'm
gonna venmo i'm an event there's a
try i'm gonna i'm gonna venmo you in
response to this sweet shoe
thank you there we go um
you will make money from that tweet
though troy no i will
directly or indirectly you will how
someone will re you've had in the times
that you tweeted it you've had a couple
of retweets you'll get more that'll put
you in front of more people which will
gain you some followers you will
incrementally
increase your standards replied and
financial
uh impact as a result of that you like
that's why you know that
also wearing this shirt can do that as
well do you know that awesome
anything party anything yeah in public
in a public square you walk in and
you're
we're all we're all doing business in on
twitter right we're all we're all
kind of totally own that totally the
whole pre-intensive like i'm not here
for shame and self-promotion like then
get off the platform because that's what
the platform is for
it's for shameless self-promotion um
i i'm justin long by the way if you're
not following him on instagram
is actually pretty pretty incredible um
and and the name i haven't thought about
in a while dude he started podcasting
and he's really really good i've i've
met him briefly
he's a good dude um but he's
always liked that fun sam raimi movie
that he was in dragged me to hell
oh yeah i still love him in the galaxy
quest
okay um god damn it guys stop it already
um i would pay you to stop
i was gonna i think this is a tweet that
cost you more than all right
there we go then paid me i just
whenever there is money exchanged for a
but pam showed me this bag that she had
and she kind of did discarded hadn't
thought
about it but i have had a an improper
definition of the word amateur
and they it comes from the greek word
that i'm gonna i'm gonna mess up i can't
even save
but an amateur by definition is a person
who engages in a pursuit especially a
sport
on an unpaid basis or who does it purely
for the passion
rather than for them for profession and
i think that that is something that is
an important distinction because
we have yeah i haven't either the word
originally for greek
had nothing to do with like i'm just an
amateur it's like
you don't do anything you could be an
amateur who was paid as long as you were
passionate is what what you're saying no
no no
no i've i've actually used this word
this way but i stopped because i
realized colloquially it's not really in
use
this way right uh everybody's assuming
amateur basically is
a presumption of lower skill but it just
means unpaid
oh it's always saying something but you
can be better and often is better than a
professional
even more so is well i wouldn't argue
often because
usually when someone gets really good at
a thing they start realizing i can
monetize this so
the trend is towards professionalization
how can i monetize my passions but this
this is why i look at in some ways an
amateur is very
cautiously do i use this term a bit more
of a purist because the
the the intent it's not the the
reception or the the
external thing that defines it but
rather the intent behind it
is that i'm just doing this because i
love to do it i am an amateur musician
there have been times i've received
money never made money from my music
that's a very important distinction
no matter what people think i have never
ever profited
from my music well i mean that's like
this podcast does that make us
purest amateur podcasters because we
don't have
that doesn't make you an amateur it
makes you a bad business
right well this is where that makes me
bad at business
if i open up a restaurant and it flops
in two weeks i'm not an amateur cook
i tried to be a professional and failed
at it right right but we're not trying
to use with this podcast right so would
that mean
right yeah no this is yes this is an
amateur but we all profit in different
ways from this point
i guess that was the broader point i was
saying i can see the bumps in my wish
listing whenever i say the word wishlist
on this show
i will get it it's also not the intent
the intent is not for us and this has
been a very purposeful thing
the intent has never been for us to make
this vocational but rather keep it
recreational
sure yeah hang out with a weird
byproduct where people comment on how we
look on it
[Laughter]
that's great language evolves and words
you know dictionaries are not
prescriptive they're descriptive as has
been discussed here before
and uh i think anybody that's like a
weird
language gatekeeper is kind of missing
the missing the point
uh uh and therefore amateur
video games podcast has a stated opinion
on the mutability of english language
that's amazing
that's solid the um the uh so the word
amateur
like to me the word i mean
it's kind of weird me too right
unskillful and
or inept is the colloquial new
definition of it but yeah
i don't know how amateur game devs who
are better than game devs who are
but that's where i personally would you
know people who have like real jobs that
pay them five times the amount and then
do this as a hobby
yeah that's why i think hobbyist is a
better word for it than amateurs
has been has been kind of rebranded as
somehow lesser than professional
like you have amateurs and pros but if
you look at
right etsy is like an entire
professional platform for hobbyists
yeah and if the distinction is simply
paid versus unpaid
i don't think that's what it is though i
think the distinction is i'm just
i know i'm saying if the if the
technical difference you're wrong
different
every single one of us is just caught
awesome now
jesus well all of us just cut you off
sorry carry on all right
they'll have my back in the comments
it's all good
the um if the distinction is between
paid and unpaid
that's why i prefer hobbyist versus
professional
because amateur is too easily conflated
to mean lesser skilled where
because they're you know we've just it's
gotten diluted there's people mean
different things
but i and that's where i and but i will
take issue with the premise that
there's some there's something somehow
more pure or
you know i know you didn't use this word
troy but enlightened
by the person that is so driven by the
love of it that
that it's not about the money to me
there's a i don't make that distinction
i don't make that distinction
well you said there is something more
pure though and that's why i said very
very cautiously it's like
there's someone who's like hey man i'm
really wanting to make a go at this
and this is how i want to provide for my
family this is how
i want to see if i can't uh i'm i'm
willfully moving into the lane of an
industry
rather than man i'm just doing this
because i want to do it i i really don't
i don't want to um
i don't want to introduce another reason
for this
other than the pure
exercise of me doing this but that's not
intrinsically
better than anything i'm not saying that
it's better okay i'm not saying that
it's
it's uh it's it's better or again less
doesn't accept passion as a payment
unfortunately otherwise
i would think for sure but like again
one of my favorite
phrases by david milch is the exegesis
of the artist situation are always of
the financial it's always like if
i am an artist how can i continue to
create my art
if if there's any art that i'm creating
even if if i'm a sculptor i need to be
able to buy the tools in order to buy
the tools i have to sell the art
most of the of the world's famous pieces
of art were commissioned gigs
they were not labors of love the david
is one of the few exceptions
where he was just like i just really
want to make this thing nobody asked him
to make that nobody paid him to make
that
most of the things that they did they
did history of classical music is the
same
same thing beethoven mozart all these
composers were absolutely working for on
commission
oh yeah bach most famously was one of
the mo where
he had these these church gigs where he
had to basically write a mass
weekly and was you know just cranking
out he had
insanely the snl of its day
yeah and these were people like the
music library you know or
he just had to endless it was all about
churn you know
and these these were not deeply devoted
religious people
either they were like [ __ ] this
institution they thought the same thing
you'd think that michelangelo's not bach
but yeah black was different yeah i see
where you're coming from just like
you know i have wanted to be a writer my
entire life i studied for it
i did it all through school and i'm now
doing it professionally because it's all
i want to do
so by choice all the time that's what i
want to do so for me to choose a
different job just to write as a hobby
wouldn't make any sense when i still
write as a hobby outside of my job
but sure in high school i ducks to my
art class and ducks in australia means
you got the top marks of the class oh so
i thought that you meant you put
feathers and a bill on yeah
it was great i thought it meant that you
published the addresses
no i got ducks of class which basically
just means you've got the top marks in
the class and then the next year
and also a duck yes the next year
the next year i pulled out i stopped
doing art because
i had realized that doing art as a
subject
at school despite getting good marks for
it made me do it less in my own time
because i was like falling into the
structure of well i need you to paint
this way to show that you can do this
thing and
something about the the theory of that
practice made me just stop doing art so
i was like i know that this is
gonna get me good grades and will help
me get into university
but i decided against doing it but i
don't feel like that probably so so
that's what i'm saying i feel i
understand where you're coming from
where like sometimes
passion is better to be kept away from
professionalism and i feel like i kept
that more pure by not doing it even in
school i wasn't getting paid for that
but i don't feel like that applies to
everything i don't think it's
whoa uh i when i say pure again i don't
want to say it was better it's simply
undiluted from from foreign elements
okay iron
is something that is naturally
inherently a weak element it's actually
made stronger by the impurities that you
add to it
and that's how we get steel is we add
impure things
to iron and that's where we get the
strongest you know one of the strongest
materials on on the planet
but i a buddy of mine was a
a wicked golfer like as a kid he he was
a protege like if people were looking at
him
or prodigy rather they were like i can't
believe how how well you can play
this sport and so people naturally are
going
you're this good we should start leading
you towards this and so
he started playing at high school teams
and it was like you can get a full ride
at college you're like
you're going to go all the way he's like
i if i look at a golf club now
i just it puts me in a bad place i feel
like that's so complicated as a parent
that's the thing that i think about all
the time is like if a kid is good at
something do you go be
extra good at it keep doing it or do you
go like whatever you want man
my my thing with traveler is this if you
quit it out of frustration
that's when we'll have a conversation
but if you quit it out of
out of autumn just like a not even
boredom
because i had a a friend of mine quite
out of satisfaction you know like yeah
it's like i did you guys
anymore yeah that then it's like let's
walk away but if there's ever a moment
where you're quitting out of anger
boredom frustration um
that that's what i'm like you have to
press through you can't quit right now
because i had a friend of mine who i've
only taken professional music lessons
once and it was for the base and it was
for a buddy that i went to church with
he was like
i just have one rule um when you get
bored don't quit
because you will get bored and if you
get bored that means you're a that means
you've learned everything out of this
level that you need and you have to push
through
interesting our our pediatrician um
changed my whole view of like the quote
terrible twos
and he was like it's only terrible for
the adults you think it's frustrating
for you try being a two-year-old who
doesn't have the systems to be able to
communicate he was like
we need this age of frustration in order
for him to go
speak and this is how it gets born out
of you
so it's like that that scene in um a
fifth element where it's like
we're attacking the the tissue with
ultraviolet rays and the body has to
respond which means growing skin
i was like that's exactly what's
happening with traveler right now and we
just let him get frustrated
instead of going hey calm down quiet
him for us i think it's the same thing
with other people
and and that's why we quit golf that's
why we quit writing it's because
either gets frustrated or the passion
dies out or someone pushes us in a place
where
we don't want it to go it's like you're
really good at this i see parents do
this with kids all the time with sports
we should not have 16 year old kids with
lifetime long maladies that that like
i have a bad back now or i blew out my
knee at
15. it's like you got a lot of life to
live man
i don't agree with that at all it raises
uh it raises an interesting
way of thinking that i hadn't quite
thought of before where you think of
someone like the
like because the distinction that kind
of uh
got me stewing just now is
we do this show conscientiously
like we'll never be doing ad reads and
things like that we there
there is no goal to you know
maximally monetize what we're doing here
and
and that would feel like we've drifted
off course if we
did even though i think it's safe to
assume that
that the show has some kind of value
and uh so mike showed up
people have
the the the um my initial instinct was
to say
it's not about it like this pure version
of passion versus
now i just have to find a way to
monetize it as if it's sort of like two
different expressions of love but
i wonder if it's kind of like on a
spectrum where
we for example love doing this show
and the things that you
onboard by
monetizing it constitute
a kind of headwind that we then have to
push through
which means that it's it's not about oh
it's the purity i would do it i don't
want to do it for money it's that
we don't love it enough the way we do
our
core professions where we do love it
sufficiently to push through those
headwinds
and overcome the additional things that
you onboard by making it now a
commercial endeavor i mean
it's actually it's also it's also true
that's right it's that none of the four
of us
needs the extra income that that would
generate sure right part of it like that
we're
none of us are hungry for extra money
nuts but i think if we were this show
would be
opportunity cost in the way the show
wouldn't even exist
because i think the time spent on the
show would not yield the return
agreed if we were that financially close
to the edge
the show would actually be holding us
back i think
just by virtue the show could make money
like significant amounts of money if we
did ads like it wouldn't be difficult at
all
um no but i think that the second that
we start doing that
it wouldn't be this show anymore right
so i just don't want to that's a
separate
i just really don't want it i see what
you're saying is like
i think it would make the show less fun
if we were to monetize the show is my
thing
which if austin your point is
we don't love it enough that is in
theory true if we were all to be like
all each of us quit our jobs and just do
this full-time and make this daily
i think that would be correct i don't
love it enough to do that because i
happen to really like my job
by the way uh the tweet that came out um
i will you know one of the things that i
love best about my job is it's basically
impossible to quit my job because i'm
fired every day you're fired you can't
quit i fire you you can't fire me i quit
well it's
true though like yeah i have to reapply
for my job
yeah like i i i don't quit my job i
would literally quit
my whole way of life it's it it would be
there is no i don't have a job per se to
quit have you ever quit a production
i have um yeah
uh it's rare um i've had
i've had i've had times where i said i
don't think i'm
the right person and it was an
unfortunate discovery
after having already signed a deal but
it's it's usually rare because normally
my attitude is like how can i
what can i learn from this environment
you know how do i how is this a
teachable moment
to get to the finish line somehow some
way
um i have had a situation where it was
it was a blurry distinction on if i quit
or i was fired because i basically
offered to leave and then they basically
were like
you know we were going to say that first
so
uh i'm pretty sure the mutual fund was
fired
it was it was a mutual breakup but one
that they arrived at the conclusion
before i did so boxes were already
packed in by the door
yeah i might leave yeah
yeah exactly but now before security
gets here i want you to know i'm leaving
yeah exactly exactly it's pretty it has
happened
uh it's generally speaking pretty rare
for composers in general
um just because you know but it's it
yeah it has
and and i've i've and i've been tempted
multiple times where it just feels like
we're just we're just banging our head
against the wall and
and we're somehow not in sync and you
should be
you should find someone who you're in
sync with but usually i get stubborn and
i'm like no
it's not like the notes don't exist i
someone else could find them which means
i should have the capacity to find them
so god damn it i'm gonna stick it
through and
you know sometimes that results in being
fired
and uh and most of the time fortunately
you find it hopeful sometimes it's like
indiana jones pulling the
you know grabbing the whip at the last
fraction of a second
under the door and like you get it off
the off the line you know
the day before launch but and then you
end up in front of
a bunch of you know indigenous people
that are aiming an arrow at your head
and that has that has happened to
multiple composers bellock looking at
you going
dr jones there's nothing that you can
tell uh have that i cannot take away
that uh austin you were wondering what
time the sun comes up it was about five
minutes ago
here we are glorious good morning
everybody which is
six four my name is gloria gloria's son
very good on that note i need to go
yeah yeah we should wrap it up because
we don't efficiently
we don't
brought to you by garlic exactly
uh it would be kind of an ironic
self-hating thing wouldn't it
yeah it wouldn't be the first time
this episode is brought to you by kotaku
[Laughter]
all right see you next week everybody